هؤلاء هم مدافعون مدنيون لأوكرانيا يحملون
السلاح ومستعدون
للقتال
من هنا ، فهذه
دمائه على الأرض
موجودة بالفعل هنا في إحدى ضواحي العاصمة
هنا ، هناك دم
أراق رصاصة صغيرة
كان أهلي هنا واه مغطاة
بهذا الاتصال المميت بين  هؤلاء
المتطوعون
والقوات الروسية ، نعم ،
لم أذهب إلى هناك من قبل ، لم أقم ببيع
جيش
لم تخدمه مطلقًا في متطوعين مثل
يوري الذي كان محللًا اقتصاديًا
أخبرني به قبل أن
جعله الغزو الروسي مقاتلًا ، لقد أطلقت النار  في
المدرسة ، أنت تعمل في مكتب ولكنك الآن
تدافع عن بلدك مدينتك ، صحيحًا ،
لم أكن أعتقد أنني سألتحق
بهذه الوحدة
قبل يومين
فقط اعتقدت أنك تعرف
أنني لا أعرف كيفية التعامل مع اللثة
والأمس  جاءني أنك تعلم أن
الروس في المدينة ،
أعني أنها
قريبة من النقطة التي
غيرت فيها رأيي تمامًا وقررت أنه
يجب أن أفعل شيئًا حيال ذلك
قبل ساعات فقط من هذا ولا  كانت
ضاحية ثيرن كييف في أوبلون مسرحًا لمعارك نارية حيث تجوب
القوات الروسية
العاصمة الأوكرانية
الآن المدينة بأكملها وسكانها
يستعدون
ويستعدون للمزيد.
وقد صنعت هذه الأشياء بنفسك ليس
الأشخاص من هذا
المبنى يجلبون لي هذا
وقد تكون هناك حاجة
قريبًا جدًا
بمجرد مغادرتنا المبنى ،
حيث يبدو أن هجوم روسيا على هذه المدينة
في متناول اليد
بشكل جيد ، فنحن ما زلنا في منتصف
حظر التجول هنا في عاصمة أوكرانيا
ليس فقط لأن الوضع
خطير للغاية وأن مسؤولي أكيفا يريدون
إبعاد مواطنيهم عن الشوارع ولكن
لأنهم يخشون أيضًا من وجود
فرق من المخربين الروس تعمل
في المدينة الآن طوال الصباح
وبعد الظهر  لقد سمعنا
عدة انفجارات كبيرة في
اللحظات القليلة الماضية فقط كان هناك بعض قادم
آه من الشمال الشرقي خارج
المدينة ، غالبًا ما يكون الأمر صعبًا  لنتحدث عن
مكان حدوث ذلك بالضبط ، لكن
كل هذا يأتي بعد ليلة شديدة التوتر
حيث كنا نسمع تحذيرات
حول ما كان يمكن أن يكون
قصفًا روسيًا للمدينة لم
يتحقق فعليًا ولكن في
ساعات الصباح الباكر فقط  بعد منتصف الليل
، وقع انفجاران كبيران في
جنوب غرب المدينة بالقرب
من ثاني أكبر مطار في كيف ، والآن
نشهد أيضًا قتالًا كبيرًا
في خاركيف ، ثاني
أكبر مدن روسيا وأوكرانيا في الجزء الشمالي
الشرقي من البلاد بالقرب من
الحدود الروسية  أه هناك
معارك شوارع تدور
بين القوات الأوكرانية والروسية
أه أهالي خاركيف قيل لهم أه
بالبقاء داخل منازلهم
والاحتماء لكن واضح في اليوم الرابع من
هذا الغزو الروسي أن الأمر لا
يسير وفق خطتهم هم
يكافحون أكثر بكثير مما كانوا
يتوقعون بالتأكيد أنهم لا يتمتعون
بتفوق جوي ، فهم لا يسيطرون
على سماء أوكرانيا.
القوات تتصدى
بشكل كبير أه المقاومة الأوكرانية أه
يقتل أفرادها أه
دروعهم ودباباتهم
تتدمر خطوط إمدادهم
وهم يواجهون صعوبة في
الحصول على أشياء مثل الوقود
خبراء أجانب مسؤولون عسكريون
معجبون بالطريقة  أن
الجيش الأوكراني كان صامدًا ، لكن من
الواضح
أنهم يواجهون قوة ساحقة ،
الرئيس زيلينسكي هذا
الصباح ، يدعو مرة أخرى ليس فقط
الأوكرانيين إلى حمل السلاح ضد
القوات الروسية ، ولكن بالقول إن أي شخص
من الخارج يريد المجيء إلى هنا
والقتال ضد  الروس هم أيضا سوف
يتم تسليحهم من قبل أوكرانيا سوزان
لك